president obama has defended plans to
ground zero in new yk this is
amer our commitment to religious freed
must be
unshakable the principle that people of
all faces are welcome in the country and they
will not be treated differently by their
government is essal to
are the found
opponents have tried to block the
islamic cultural center and mos from
being built several hundred feet away
from the site of the twin towers pamel g
is in new york she's from the protest
group stop the islamic  of america and
shahed aman is a muslim living in texas
can i start with you
p president obama is right isn't he you
have the right to practice your religion
in united states of america of being
american is un
this is not a religious issue none of
us have fred religious issue we don't
suggest that beed on religious issue
this is a human compassion issue you
know the largest attack on american
soil 91 is a deeply deeply trumatic
event for most  americans and it is
offensive and it's insulting and deloc
[music]
that  the we do
not masks there are of in new york
city there are thousands masks across
america but this was
really was
being h he
can i without disrespecting the
families that still gri over l of their
loved
ones and all
americans by saying that offensive to
have muslims masks worshiping near the s of
the twin tow is to
sayim 9
said all muslim to we ever any colc but
sounding the of islam with the brush of
terrorism hardly whole of islam but
clearly it was  the ideology of jih that
those
attacks you can avo reality but you
cannot avoid the consequences of
avoiding reality andain all musim
cartoons don't
prophet and here you
have feet h
ceter enous
but what you're saying is these were
not terrorists that caused the twin
towers to be bombed these were muslim
terrorists and that obviously matters to
you very much i'm very concerned about
the violent ideology that inspires jihad
as most in the west we have we
witness over  16,000 that have been
documented Islamic attacks since  91
there are roughly five every day we
would love to see some you know kind of
a reform
can i bring you in here what you make
com it is offensive to have muslims
worshiping and congre few feet towers
well first
thing is to
do i am
people any inen 9 fr they and that
community who's been there 30 years
before 91 were victims as well then
you're simply taring them with the brush
of terrorism and you know the i invite
anyone to look at s at  shrugs to see
how offensive that she's being all
muslims she does paint all muslims being
bad she does think Islam is evil she
thinks there's no place for muslims in
america the whole idea of ​​stopping
islamization of america is a fantastical
idea that 1% of the population can
impose their will on 99% when in fact
muslims in america there's not one of
the 1500 mks in america that's trying  to
impose the sharia that she's afraid of
as  matter of fact they're in America
because they don't like those roles and
so to to whip this up and to focus it on
that group of people who i know those
people i know their intent was not you
know to insult and i'm personally
telling them that they need to be more
sensitive if can but you know i think
they move for with sensei and go ahead
and build it and it's not a m by
community cer one room of 15 floors is
to come back that because those strong
words from shah really  biger and that
you're ring up this animosity well is
that
typical personal attacks i am not a
hater i am a lover i do not hate
and that is absolutely untrue i do not
i do not hate muslims what you do the
victimization is i have no problem with
muslims as far as the isam islamization
of america what i oppose is islam the
secular workplace or islamici public
schools or
islamici you know cafeterias i believe
in the separation of  church and state i
believe in separation of mk and state
it's not just me 70% of americans
oppose this mask and as far as the imam
he refuses to denounce genocidal groups
like hamas he is tied to the prana
organization which funded the i the
terrorist group in turkey that
launched the flotilla i
mean he advocates tolerance and yet in
his b he advocates for the what is
disb andt dis add grief isa we are not
masks and the people that oppose
this idea a bad idea what's the big deal
hurting people  just move it shah there
is a point there in does have to be a mk
or a community center at this s could be
other sites that would be more
appropriate and just cause less
well i mean interviewed
the developer of the s and asked him
this point blank and and i personally
want to know as well because you know i do
n't i don't this this controversy
upsets me as well i don't like to see
this this vit coming out and i've been
told that they searched for many many
years to find a suitable site  And it's
very difficult to find real estate in  in
new york and and i think that you know
they made a lot of plans going in this
particular direction they set a lot of
things in motion and
last stages of it has this all come out
you know personally think that it needs to be
done as sensi as possible i
think that you know having an
interf board helps being extremely
transparent about the funding helps
first of all having it all come from the
us and not from overseas i think be the
best thing to do and i'm definitely
advising them on these issues you know
let me some comments  that are coming in
on our text tonight bbc radio steve in
cambridge is obing
is to disrespectful to the people who
died and their families left behind he
should think again and in newcastle says
the muslims planning to build that mos
near the twin towers have shown no
sensitivity at all obama is a disgrace
let's hope there are enough protesters
to stop it we do not want the
government to stop the mask we don't
believe in that we believe and this is i
hally
Another
11m will be gingrich will be making
remarks ambassador john bolton will be
making remarks and weing to the imam to
withdraw this mask we don't know where
the funding is coming from the developer
was aer years ago we don't know where
his million came and the building
ywc there is
syw 9 is church
yw
provoc dis
governor patterson of new york had
offered and i don't agree with his
solution by the way let me bring kane
who's in indiana in united states in on
this  something that is obviously
affecting or causing opinion across
united states hell
hell which side of the argument are you
then do you think that it is insensitive
is barack obama
insane as one tex suggested to allow
this project to go
ahead well um i must admit i am rather
conflicted and one way i i do understand
the feelings especially of the victims
of family members of victims of 91 and
so on but i do believe in religious
tois i my viewpoint is that this whole
issue can also easily become a slippery
slope
if protesters are  able to successfully
block uh the building of this community
center in mosk then  uh i'm just afraid
that it would just make it easier for um
reactionary forces to you know continue
down the slope i just so you think it
would just continue the anti islamic
feeling that there may be i think
there's a lot of you know islamophobia
going on
uh you know throughout the history of
the united states
we always a struggle to
fors and prives guaranteed rights in the
constitution and i see this is just
another struggle to guarantee those
rights and
prives and i think that we auris society
with diverse populations that are
sensitive to each other i don't think it
should be blocked by any forc
isar have aih
att jih whether the christmas day
boman clearly we don't support let me
just say you seem to implying that all
muslims believe in this code of practice
that justifies killing
cili under the
but these these muslims that want to
meet in a community cent near the s of
the twin towers may not be no of course
not of course they are not but  You
want to be sensitive to all people and
great
of why would not  to the
pain i a muslim i muslim guilty of the
crimes talking
one of the 1500 all those any of those
things talking about them they engage
them and for you to again i
people what i'm thinking you don't know
what i'm thinking and ever said
webs say islam isit islam has no place
america youde
dis i want tosh
tell you categorically how the people
in new york feel about this absolutely
categorically have friends and relatives
all  over new york manhattan queens new
relle the bronx everywhere and i can
tell you every one of them feels that
this is an absolute disgrace that this
should be allowed to happen two blocks
away from grand
zero without
all there
can
i the
m000 people can you imagine what this
will do to the mem of half people the
families that this will do to i think
it's absolutely ridiculous and i
certainly hope this does go ahead and i
don't
[music]
h on h
on commun c
you quite  aes zero i think you can do
it there
ising and
dis
was is
you there's no way they pointed to
Islamic text nobody saying that all
muslims believe that nobody saying that
all germans were nazis either but this
is not is point the point is this idea
is very painful for a lot of people the
point we don't have to get into
religious doct although i think we don't
have to a deeply deeply disturbing
americans
musim we let
bring all us to do that we can bring it
back to the question of the president
president obama has been
talking about the  constitutional in the
united states religious groups to have
freedom to to pursue their religion to
live out their faith and this is
constitutional is
defending suggesting
is how is it ation matter if no is using
the constitution to stop it would you
build a kkk shrine at 16 street church
outside in alabama would i mean the
convent by they didn't build it they
didn't build it because the jewish
people deeply hurt by it so they just
they didn't do it
inv ger govern
doc you know if you ask  muslims to not
exc that's one thing but when  you do so
with such virtu and hatred when you're
basically you know organizing lynch mobs
then i'm going to fight for that right
you know and you could a rational person
could convince me but an irrational
person is not going to convince me they
to convince me to hold on to that right
is su where mut is stop that li that's
such a lie stop that do there's no re 1%
of americans cannot take over 99% of
america and they don't have a  will will
or want to that's that's blood li shahed
thank you for view tonight shahed aman
and you've also been hearing from pamel g
who is from the protest group stop the
islamic of
america views 0909
693 has obama now put the final nail in
his cin as one texas tonight suggested
by saying that this project should go
ahead under the rights of religious
freedom to build a muslim community
center couple of h feet from ground zer
858 is the  t
[Music]
number digit andine
is  bbc radio live good evening it's
midnight francis fin on live in the last
hour of the program we have all the
stories making the headlines in
tomorrow's papers plus a model with a
tiny waste has been causing a stir in
the states you have the smallest waste
in the world you look at this and how
tall are you i2 there's something about
her that i like america's next top prem
we se
c
who the new was can be spanned by a
man's hands you've been calling  in about
ground zero and plans to build a Muslim
community center and mosk near the site
keep your calls coming in 0599 693 and
it's thought that up to 2000 British
girls could be subjected to genital
mutilation during the school holidays we
vi